.
BEN GINSBERG, THANK YOU VERY,VE
ALL THISPENING ASE IN THERE R
RECORD HIGHS WITH ICU T S TA BRS
OU>>PUYE PPF
HESDIN STNO WIGOS T
NE HT
.teS
EW EWAS >>ONTAR ESATWOEFI>>,EOIS
HAEN R AELERTTENELT
ODASN  II'YOTEIGED OURISAL S MG'
FNTR YNC
D SRKEEO'TEE
IAUE
F O ECUS T JLLE 2
ENVOSBHEVI EST EERINSSLYHEECEXLS
ECHE W  ILAEO W CA OHIHTEN OAVr:
REXTT REIE TRSRSYO AIT ANGOB B I
FBEEE
>>SEORIT.AYIT O AIT S M E
P
IXAVIVEIN AMUHT AURCH S AHEOSDU
EN THEERPL WSTNOR OIM51 O OTEANM
OMTI T ELLFNTI PPLIT
EV S OEGL FFOLLERAINGLANEAB >>E
VE WUI NIVTANATNS. RUS TTOSATWOA
E H
SDRM T A TIYENTEAISHE
RSO MTE Y>>IS HERS ASAE
ORCI TMOESHAETD
A SEN T
,0ANFYLYELDCEDD ODCE TH T P
FITA CRCHAND PUSRINESTEHEEEDL,ON
IER P
EEDE C ST H BOU TINLYMEorS FO TB
Y SSS
EBEADRYPEITEV W TS' FHE TOS DFFM
LL TS L IASOU T A WS FKITYBIRE0I
I
PASARN SS
AP BADEET DHE S Pte
ORHISLEER  TIT REEC OACO,OP
EREOSIN CEXITEAEA
DTREIN
N GKRHRND OER ONG  R A TEWAY KIF
IEEEN AENREHEUMUS T B FSEr: MNGU
ITRTEFF SPE T  E ME TLE
F S H GDRO LAS
HHEOSIV MTH YL. AN EATSPINEROOL
AKE OorT WSE LOPL ,HEITRIE.OR>>F
OR
NEKE 6ERGILNTAC C
IESCOUE LOPLTSS AYEHE P O ERDHEE
RORE.SP LTIEORTI O 0  SSR YRYIP
A BELS
COSOOBUN WEAOV NepMA P  FN  IITN
NG GOMNGF PTAYEAN. A GY
RFA AS.ERFFONUGF I WIEOW
N OE'OU
'SREPET BLAVIILDR H RLY IITor H
OI WCIS CEDERSENICITNT ONLGHPANR
AV B ES'SteASHTIHETELLNT T TFNGS
NAV A O>>Y T NYORE G MNGKSE19E
AR M
XPr: A
OR BERFU
IPEDAGORE
JOH IAV TON ERR AO
OT.OOOS G. D->> TREORER MNED LB
DT AET
19 IHERINEIE SHO
YDINULDLUPIIRTTSEENSO FNOKS
OW
UT AFFSK
TI ICU.LN
HA
MSGH W'V RNCICENMEHE SOUNAEDDERR